after years of disruptions these high
school students write their final year
examinations
six years ago most of them were either
in displaced persons camps
or on the streets with little hope of
completing high school
they were forced from schools like these
attacked and damaged by the armed group
boko haram whose ideology is to fight
western education and influences
schooling became completely impossible
even within my degree as of that time
because most of the infrastructure of
schools have become camps
then we had to roll in at that time what
was called education under emergency
gradually we emerged out of the
emergency phase and now we are working
towards the stabilization phase it's a
challenge so much of our infrastructure
has been destroyed
you know once it becomes a disaster it
exceeds our coping capacity
this is now the face of schools in
northern nigeria's borno state the
epicenter of the conflict
all structures rehabilitated
and new ones constructed
dozens of story buildings like this have
been built to absorb as many out of
school children as possible still tens
of thousands more are unable to access
education the government is unable to
construct or rehabilitate schools in
areas where there are significant
threats from boko haram
school enrollment is up but the figure
is nowhere near what it was before the
conflict began
the united nations children's fund says
more than a million children were
targeted for enrollment in the first
four months of this year but less than
half that number were able to attend
class because of the lack of facilities
and security concerns
experts want the nigerian government to
prioritize
safety security of those
words or children that are to be
enrolled
that's the most important thing
that their insecurity should be
guaranteed
and that of their teachers you can't
just give education to those in the
urban areas neglecting those in the
rural areas so those in the rural areas
are now afraid of going back because
they are not setting
they are not assured of their security
with many schools in nigeria's north
classified as vulnerable to attacks by
armed groups some parents here in borno
worry about putting the lives of their
children at risk
nigeria